People are on the verge of discovering our secrets
This Friday, nothing can prepare you for what's next
We just don't know what to expect
I'm fine. I'm fine.
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
marvel Wandavision sword video just explaining
what's going on with him the Monica Rambeau
character because obviously there's so much other
stuff going on with her in the mcu during marvel
phase four and with a sword agency if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos i'm doing episodes for all Wandavision
falcon and winter soldier the loki episodes later
this year there's going to be so much big stuff
happening and we're doing a giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter is
just be a subscriber and let me know what you want
to see them do with sword after the Wandavision
series careful for spoilers for everything that's
happened on Wandavision so far if you have not
seen the episodes yet but the past few episodes
of Wandavision have given us a first look at the
mcu version of adult Monica Rambeau they have
big plans for her she was a version of captain
marvel in the comics she's going to be in captain
marvel 2. she also had many other comic book names
and she's wearing her comic book uniform in this
promo for Wandavision she's a sword agent so i'll
explain what's going on with that now confirmed
as at the end of episode three that was the big
reveal scarlet witch finding out what's that
symbol what does that mean we've known since
the very first trailer that she was a sword agent
because she appears in this group of them rushing
up to the same spot outside the west view town
where scarlet witch's alternate dimension is in
that special red energy barrier we can just call
that the mcu house of m but right now it's sort of
like an alternate dimension and alternate reality
because this is all sort of setting up the concept
of the multiverse during marvel phase iv i know
a lot of you were asking if this was a mephisto
reference too because it kind of looks like an
upside down cross i suppose you could think of
it that way because there are a lot of mephisto
easter eggs because they're doing scarlet witch's
children with vision and mephisto was a big part
of that storyline so there are easter eggs for
that but in the trailer footage for episode 4 and
future episodes they just expand a lot on what's
going on with sword you see a lot more footage
of them outside this reality in present day
you see scarlet witch flying in the air using
her red energy powers while it seems like she's
trapped inside this containment cell like you see
the architecture around her here she's wearing her
modern day avengers end game costume so it seems
like this is a sword facility that they're keeping
her in and it could be a flashback to before
the events of Wandavision episode 1 or it could
be from later episodes after they sort of bring
her to her senses a little bit because there is
that other trailer footage where she's talking
to Vision about them fighting for their home
like fighting for this house of m reality tayonna
paris is the name of the actress who plays adult
Monica Rambeau she said that Wandavision picks up
immediately after the events of avengers end game
so i think what she means is is that the show
will eventually have flashbacks to the events
right after avengers end they're the funeral here
for iron man and then they think about vision like
she has that conversation with hawkeye i think
they do know that we won and then through more
flashbacks they'll show you how scarlet witch
wound up inside her house of m reality because
during episode 1 you just start the episode with
her entering the matrix quote unquote so to speak
entering her house of m reality and starting
the scenario like she metaphorically hits a play
button and starts the wanda envision greatest
hits album so what's happening right now at
the start of episode 4 is that she's been found
out by scarlet witch gets punted out with her
telekinesis and lands in the middle of the sword
agent's camp that they set up outside westview to
monitor scarlet witch like we saw darcy or someone
else watching the live video feed from inside the
alternate reality and it looked kind of like
they were just watching a nick at night episode
because that's kind of what the director wanted
to do with this version of the house of mcu story
she and the other sword agents like monica
Rambeau are just watching as scarlet witch
manifests her fantasy into reality which is
meant to be a version of her chaos magic and
reality warping powers from the comics making
fake things into real things like every time
the scenario changes and they jump to a decade she
also changes what everybody looks like what their
personalities are i talked a little about this
during my episode 3 video and i'll put a link
for that in the description because it's really
important for how billy and tommy the brand new
twins wicken and speed from the comics continue
to exist in the mcu after Wandavision is over
and you also notice that she created monica
Rambeau'a clothes because before she goes into
this alternate reality she looks like this this is
her regular modern day sword uniform as she's just
standing here in this lab with darcy and jimmy wu
notice the sword logo on her shirt in this tv down
here you see her wearing what looks like a quantum
suit just like hank pym's suit from ant-man and
the wasp and then in the other new trailer footage
for episode 4 in the future episodes you see her
piloting a ship through this barrier here that
looks kind of like hank pym's quantum ship
the quantum realm quantum energy is obviously
a big concept when you talk about multiverse
alternate timelines alternate realities so her
in the quantum suit flying through the barrier
here this is all happening before the events of
episode 2 where she shows up at this poolside
meeting like hello my name is geraldine but per
jimmy woo's dialogue randall park's character in
the radio here right up to this scene here where
scarlet witch goes all thanos on Monica Rambeau
all the sword agents have no idea what's causing
this and what's happening to her they thought
that scarlet witch was being held here against her
will like some evil marvel villain was making her
do something the big reveal the big wtf twist
is that she's the one controlling everything
at least as far as we know i think a lot of us are
also expecting some deeper layers to this because
scarlet witch isn't a straight up villain but she
has been an antagonist to the avengers in the past
so this is them just leaning a little into that
story like yes she's doing very bad things but she
herself is not a villain more easter eggs for that
too fake things becoming real things when Monica
Rambeau's getting punted out they play the monkey
song daydream believer the monkeys were a fake
band that then became a real band they were fake
band created for the monkey's tv show but then
became a band in real life going around playing
shows the acronym for sword in the mcu stands for
sentient weapon observation and response team so
nick fury created this separate team from shield
mostly to study super-powered people in artificial
intelligences like the infinity stones in robots
androids like vision we talk about living weapons
remember that the infinity stones are alive they
have a consciousness of their own and a will that
they can exert on people they kind of got into
that during the first avengers movie a little and
during avengers age of ultron but by the time we
got to infinity war and endgame they treated them
more like straight up gemstones like thanos just
plucking them in his gauntlet to use but the
mcu version of these are a little bit like the
ring of power in the lord of the rings series
they can exert their will on people who aren't
strong enough to wield them so with the advent of
the infinity stones and then seeing people like
scarlet witch vision other super powered people
pop up ever since the events of the captain
marvel movie nick fury probably got the idea to
create a sword agency specifically to address that
whereas shield handled more general earth-based
problems like traditional law enforcement
agencies i think part of the idea with the sword
agency though is that nick fury because he never
trusted anyone and knew that there was a big
problem inside shield created sword in partnership
with the scrolls because he has this sword space
station at the end of spider-man far from home
and he wouldn't be able to build that without the
scrolls technology and their resources but because
it's so big it would have taken him a long time to
create that meaning that he was probably working
on building it for a long time all while shield
was in the process of eating itself alive through
marvel phase 2. there's a very kevin feige sort of
reveal in the mcu like this thing has been around
this whole time we just haven't shown you and then
in future stories they reveal what was happening
and why you didn't see it till now but Monica
Rambeau being a sword agent in present day is
also the link back to the captain marvel movies
they introduced the scrolls she's a little girl
we see marvel space station in orbit fast forward
to present day nick fury has a much bigger version
of that space station hiding in orbit cloaked
after wanda vision Monica Rambeau will go to
captain marvel 2 i know a lot of people are
wondering if she's going to get her powers from
the comics during Wandavision or if they'll save
that for captain marvel 2 i'm assuming they'll
probably tease that at the end of Wandavision and
then they'll really pay it off during the movie
the new ms marvel kamala khan is also supposed to
be in that movie too but we're not going to see
her episodes till way later this year so i know a
lot of you are also asking about inhumans as well
because ms marvel is an inhuman in the comics i
don't know how they plan to address that but it's
still possible that they invoke the inhumans in
some way even though originally the whole reason
for them doing that terrible terrible inhuman
series was because marvel could not do x-men
series now that they have control those characters
again they can do whatever they want you don't
really have to do inhumans if you don't want to
but i'm sure when we get that first ms marvel
trailer they'll have a way of explaining that but
the whole thing here is that the sword agents just
now figured out the scarlet witch is kind of the
villain of this scenario at least for right now
they still want to help her in some way but she
is the sentient weapon in this scenario along
with vision that they're trying to quote unquote
respond to per the acronym in the comics it's
sentient world observation in response department
and they're mostly tasked with dealing from
threats outside of planet earth threats from other
dimensions threats from deep space cosmic threats
like the celestials things like galactus big
fantastic four style problems so i have a feeling
that the mcu version of this sword agency will
also just combine a lot of that comic book stuff
with this new sentient weapon observation and
response stuff like they have that avengers secret
invasion series starring nick fury in talos's
scroll character it's going to be a scroll based
secret invasion series there'll also be a lot
of sword stuff happening during that as well
but everyone let me know in the comments where
else do you want to see Monica Rambeau and the
sword agents show up in marvel phase 4. my full
Wandavision episode 4 video will post friday just
like normal make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss any of that everyone
click here for my full Wandavision episode 3 video
and click here for that brand new godzilla vs kong
trailer thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!